matthew taylor um
should nhs employees be required to be
vaccinated as a condition of employment
uh i think that that is not necessary um
the overwhelming majority of nhs staff
are choosing to be vaccinated
and the important thing is to support
people give people the opportunity to be
vaccinated
so
i think we would want to say that there
is no
necessity for uh compulsion
kind of surveillance of people at this
stage because
the
staff themselves are doing the right
thing
so you wouldn't uh be putting any energy
into
consulting on that as the
minister told us he was going to do
earlier on
i think if we felt that there was a a
real issue
there then
um you know it is something that needs
to be addressed of course health service
workers like anybody else need to take
responsibility for the decisions they
make and the implications they have for
other people but you know i i think that
what we should focus on is the fact that
overwhelmingly nhs staff
are doing the right thing and indeed you
know working beyond their hours and have
been dealing now for you know 18 months
with
a national crisis and dealing with it uh
heroically so
you know i think the question is not
are there some nhs staff who aren't
vaccinated the question is how do we
support
those nhs staff who have been
doing what we need them to do through
this crisis
let's look at
sorry let's look at what's got what's uh
in prospect if the government decides to
uh vaccinate 12 to 15 year olds uh or to
offer booster jab to
older people do you think the system is
resilient enough to cope with that
demand
well we've
seen heroic efforts in terms of
vaccination
and that continues
and there are issues about
supply their issues about capacity and
clearly the government has to make
decisions in terms of who it is that it
prioritizes in relation to this and
these are difficult choices nobody
pretends that they're not
in terms of making a booster um
available to people like myself or the
people who've had two vaccinations and
also to
younger people because of the importance
of ensuring not just trying to minimize
infection rates but also to ensure that
young people are able to carry on in
education
so you know the health service stands
ready as it has done over the last 18
months if given the resources
to lead this national vaccination
program which has so far been a major uh
success but
you know trevor this is part of the the
question of living with uh covid and you
know the first
part of the vaccination program was to
get people vaccinated
and now we have to think about what is
required in terms of boosters also in
terms of
flu
vaccination so
these are hard choices it's important
that the government is open about those
choices and takes the best advice that
it can in terms of who it is we should
be prioritizing
you published a report this week which
to be honest described a system which is
pretty much on the edge you uh your
report said that covert 19 had had a
seismic impact unlike anything the nhs
has faced in its history and it to
describe the last two months as winter
in summer
do you believe that you've got the beds
and the people the trained staff to get
us through to next spring
yeah it's tough and you're absolutely
right trevor that
the leaders or members of our
organization tell us that
it feels and we're just coming out of
summer that when it feels like a
midwinter crisis all parts of the nhs
not just hospitals the ambulance service
gps community mental health services we
are running on hot
and you can't do that forever and so
that's one reason why it's incredibly
important to get some clarity from the
government
um about the funding for the rest of
this year that we sustain uh that
funding and that we have the funding
that we need on the assumption that the
pressures of covid are going to continue
and that's what it looks like is going
to happen so the two big challenges for
the health service are
funding the ongoing costs of covid and
that's the patients in hospital over
7000 in hospital right now ppe
um the pressure on mental health
services long hovid which is a major
issue and then secondly the backlog we
have
as we know well over five million people
on waiting lists the secretary of state
himself has said that he thinks that
that vehicle rise uh a great deal more
and we need to fund that care as well
now yes there are major issues about
workforce there are issues about uh the
kind of capacity that we have but
it is important to say that if you give
the health service the resources that it
needs it does the job
and even in these last few months while
we're still coping with covid we have
seen substantial progress in relation to
those people who've been waiting the
longest time
and we've seen progress also in other
critical areas like making sure that we
are checking people for the danger of a
cancer diagnosis so
despite these pressures where the nhs
has the resources it makes a difference
but we need that resourcing to to
continue
firstly for the rest of this year and
then for the years ahead